the Central Mosque in Simferopol the
Crimean Tatars meet here for Friday
prayers the Muslim minority here feels
especially threatened by Russian
sabre-rattling you can imagine what the
mood is like here kids are asking their
parents whether there will be a war
everyone is frightened the Crimean
Tatars pray hoping against hope that
history won't repeat itself in 1944 the
Soviet leader Joseph Stalin ordered that
the Tatars be deported on mass from the
peninsula
they were resettled in Siberia and
Central Asia many still harbor fierce
hatred for Russia following prayers the
Tatar leader in Crimea's parliament
referred chubarov addressed his people
he made an urgent call for unity and
calm asking for a boycott of a planned
referendum on independence of the region
even though chubarov is a member of the
regional parliament he considers the
body's actions to be illegal the risk of
the situation escalating is high he says
more wood wood was nurtured in the could
lead to bloodshed for all ethnic groups
in the Crimean region we call on the UN
to take action and send peacekeepers to
the region as quickly as possible
middle school boys it's exceptional and
it shows the tension and the fear that
the political leader of the tatar
minority here in the region is talking
to its people right inside the mosque
after the prayers his main message is
that the international community has to
get much more involved here in the
region to prevent the situation from
getting even worse